in tropical rainforests a war has been
raging for millions of years a war
between ant colonies and the different
types of fungi that infect them it's a
battle that has led to an arms race of
evolution creating one of the most
sinister methods of survival ever
discovered
parasites in general need a host animal
to reproduce and survive
and ants are a tempting host animal for
parasites indeed up to 70 percent of the
individual insects in a rainforest are
ants
in theory this should provide a large
pool of potential victims for infectious
and parasitic types of fungus
thus just like our megacities ants face
a huge risk of disease outbreaks that
can potentially wipe out an entire
colony therefore ants put up formidable
defenses against such invasions they
work together to groom each other clean
of pathogens and if one of their
comrades does get infected it is exiled
from the colony and if a dead ant is
discovered by its peers it is quickly
removed then dumped far away from the
colony before the disease can spread
this is all a sometimes ruthless but
effective way to keep diseases at bay
but in the spinning wheel of evolution
defenses like this can be outmaneuvered
and overcome and one type of fungus has
done this in an almost unimaginable way
to see evidence of this strategy you'd
need to venture deep into the rainforest
in a place like thailand
then you'd need to lean down and look
for leaves that sit just above the
forest floor
and here on the underside of a leaf you
just might find an example of a real
life zombie an ant with its mandibles
grasped tightly on the leaf's central
vein devoid of its own life and instead
hosting the life of a strange protruding
fungus that is reproducing and spreading
its spores
days or even weeks of mind control have
led to this moment
the fungus working as the puppeteer the
ant the unfortunate victim
this type of mind control is very
precise and very insidious
and while we might hope it's isolated to
ant on the forest floor parasites of all
kinds are exceptional at altering the
behavior of their hosts to increase the
chances of transmission
zombies in a sense are all around us
how is such parasitic mind control
possible and how scared do we need to be
that parasites might take over our own
minds
[Music]
the ant species camponotus leonardi a
type of carpenter ant lives in the high
canopy of the rainforest and builds an
extensive network of aerial trails
they would happily stay up in the
treetops relative safety but sometimes
their aerial network is imperfect
if gaps between the leaves are too large
to cross the ants are forced to descend
to the forest floor
and here is where the zombie fungus
strikes
the fungus ophiocordyceps unilateralis
is a highly specialized infectious
fungus when an ant stumbles across one
of its spores the spore attaches to its
exoskeleton and eventually breaks
through using mechanical pressure and
enzymes and at this point the fungus
starts to take over
over the course of the next week
infected ants appear perfectly normal
and go about their business undetected
by the rest of the colony
then once the fungus has developed
enough inside the ant it compels the ant
to leave the safety of its nest travel
down to the forest floor and climb a
small plant stem a few centimeters off
the ground
here the ant permanently clamps its jaws
around a leaf and is completely
overtaken by the fungus
where the ant carries out its death grip
is remarkably precise
in one study every infected ant chomped
down on the underside of a leaf and 98
bit down on the leaf's vein
almost all of them did this on the north
side of the plant on a leaf exactly 25
centimeters above the ground the chosen
leaves were in an environment with 94 to
95 humidity and all ended up in a
location with temperatures between 20
and 30 degrees celsius it is no
coincidence that every one of these
factors is the optimal condition for the
cordyceps fungus to grow the zombie ant
has transported it to its exact
preferred location meaning the control
the fungus exerts over the ant is
astoundingly precise and at this precise
location a long fungus stalk eventually
bursts through the ant's head with a
bulbous capsule full of spores on the
end and the ant is killed and because
the ant typically clamps down on a leaf
in its own colony's territory the fungal
spores rain down onto other ants below
zombifying any it touches
the first zombie ant was documented over
a hundred years ago but until recently
scientists had no idea how the cordyceps
fungus could control the ant so
precisely and while there are still many
questions recent research using machine
learning is getting us closer to an
answer
to get to the bottom of the mind control
mystery scientists wanted to know what
part of the ants body the fungus infects
surely they thought the fungus mind
control ability would be focused inside
the ant's head
so they worked to identify any parts of
the ant where the fungus was present
and to their surprise they found fungal
cells not just in the ant's head but
also in the thorax and gaster
and intriguingly they also found fungal
cells in abundance inside the legs next
they wanted to see how much of the
fungus infects the brain of the ant
using a laser scanning microscope they
examined the nervous tissue in the head
of infected ants and found something
profoundly unexpected the fungus doesn't
touch the ant's brain at all
fungal cells were concentrated directly
outside the brain but none were observed
inside the brain how can the fungus
control the ants mind if its actual mind
is untouched
next they looked closer at the fungus
growing in the rest of the ants body
here they found fungal cells present
between the muscle fibers in both the
head and leg regions to quantify the
amount of fungus in each sequential
image scan they used a deep learning
algorithm that could quickly identify
fungal cells from ant tissue that could
then build a 3d model doing this by hand
would have taken months but instead they
got the result in days
scientists could then start to see that
the hyphal bodies the yeast-like
circular fungal cells were connected to
other hyphal bodies by short tubes
and that some of these hyphae invade the
ants muscles penetrating the cell
membranes and growing inside
elsewhere in the fungal world fungal
tubes like this are known to allow for
the transfer of chemicals nutrients and
information
so these connections the tubes the
penetrating fibers point to an intricate
network inside the ant's body connecting
the fungal cells to each other and to
the ants muscles
all of this suggests that the fungus
isn't using mind control to transport
itself where it needs to go
but rather muscle control in a full body
takeover the ant's mind may in fact be
completely unaffected meaning it's
trapped as a prisoner in its own body
with the fungus in control
exactly what chemical signals the fungus
sends to the ant muscles to cause it to
do its bidding is still unknown however
scientists are working hard to uncover
this last mystery of the ant zombie
phenomenon
but how common is this type of situation
is it only ants that get zombified how
worried do we need to be that the last
of us may not be just science fiction
but a premonition
ants may be the most common host for the
cordyceps fungus but they are by no
means the only ones it infects plenty of
other insects and spiders like
tarantulas or beetles leading to a
similar spectacular death however the
cordyceps fungus does not have the
zombifying ability in these other
organisms only the ants
and while this might make you want to
breathe a sigh of relief the cordyceps
fungus is far from the only parasite
capable of controlling the behavior of
its host
in fact there are dozens of examples of
parasitic mind control in the animal
kingdom the leukocloridium is a
parasitic worm that invades a snail's
eyestocks where it pulsates in a
mesmerizing way to imitate a caterpillar
the worm then mind controls the snail
out into the open to tempt hungry birds
to eat its eyestalks
once inside the bird the worm is able to
reproduce and then release its eggs in
the bird's droppings which then get
eaten up by more snails and the
parasite's life cycle is complete
then there's the emerald cockroach wasp
that attacks cockroaches with venom that
blocks a neurotransmitter that allows
the cockroach to control its own
movements
the wasp can then lead the walking
zombie roach into the wasp's nest where
it will act as a host and a food source
for the wasps larvae all of these zombie
instances seem to happen on a tiny scale
on the forest floor with snails insects
or spiders
is it possible for more complex animals
to fall victim to such an insidious
killer
for mammals it's certainly not as common
but not unheard of
in perhaps the most disturbing example
of zombie infection in mammals mice
become mind controlled by a parasite
called toxoplasma gondii which compels
them to walk straight to their own
deaths toxoplasma gondii is a parasitic
protozoan that can infect any
warm-blooded animal
but mice have particularly bad luck
because there is just one animal that
the parasite can reproduce in cats
studies have shown that toxoplasma
infection in rodents is able to change
their instinctual fear of the odor of
cats into an attraction to this odor the
infected mice and rats visit more often
and stay longer in places containing the
odor of cat urine
this naturally makes them more likely to
get eaten by a cat where the toxoplasma
parasite can complete its life cycle
and unfortunately for us we too can get
infected with this parasite
in fact one third of the entire
population already is
infection usually occurs by eating
undercooked contaminated meat or
exposure from infected cat feces
the parasite then hangs out in various
tissues including the brain pretty much
dormant for long periods of time
sometimes for the rest of your life
for decades scientists thought that the
infection in humans was relatively
harmless besides the risk it poses to
unborn babies in pregnant women but
recent studies show that that might not
be the case at all and it might mess
with us in very weird ways
a study in 2002 showed that individuals
involved in car accidents were more
likely to have such infections hiding in
their bodies
it's thought that the toxoplasma
parasite slows down reaction times
in rodents this slow reaction time would
help them get eaten by cats in us is it
just an unfortunate evolutionary
carryover or something more
a few years later a small study found
something even more strange
participants with a toxoplasmosis
infection rated the odor of diluted cat
urine as more pleasant than non-infected
participants did however weirdly this
was only true for the men in the study
and perhaps even more scary is that the
toxoplasma parasite also seems to be a
risk factor in developing schizophrenia
researchers in copenhagen found that
individuals with the infection were
almost 50 percent more likely to be
diagnosed with schizophrenia disorders
compared to those without an infection
scientists are still debating about the
mechanism here and about the causation
correlation conundrum
but as the years go on the evidence only
gets stronger for the idea that
toxoplasma is absolutely messing with
human psychology and behavior
but is there a bigger reason that this
happens the toxoplasma parasite mind
controls the mouse to be able to
reproduce and spread to other mice
is toxoplasma gondii doing the same with
us
but humans are certainly not the prey of
house cats the parasites current primary
host as much as the cats may wish that
were true
but current is the key word here
domesticated house cats have only been
around for around 9 000 years
it's likely that in the past a different
bigger cat was the parasite's primary
host
and our ancestors may have been a
primary snack
leopards in particular are extremely
good at hunting and eating primates and
they always have been
they are stealthy fast can leap into
trees where primates sleep to snatch
them and can carry heavy loads
leopard ancestors have been going after
human ancestors for millions of years
even today leopards are the cause of 70
of baboon deaths and half of a leopard's
diet consists of monkeys or chimpanzees
to see if primates may be affected by
the toxoplasma parasite the same way
mice are researchers tested the
reactions of chimps to the smell of
leopard urine
and they found that the chimpanzees not
infected with toxoplasma investigated
the smell of leopard urine less often
avoiding the smell to the best of their
ability
the chimps infected with the toxoplasma
parasite on the other hand investigated
the leopard urine far more often
their fear of it seemed to be diminished
causing them to act more recklessly just
like rodents infected with the parasite
so somewhere in our evolutionary past
it's possible that the parasite evolved
to alter our decision-making skills as
well or even attract us to our own
feline deaths
many of these studies were small and
much more research needs to be done to
fully understand the impact of
toxoplasma gondii on our brains
but these results so far have scientists
reconsidering everything they thought
they knew about the parasite while the
cordyceps fungus may never bring about
the zombie apocalypse in humans our
actions and behaviors may still be
influenced by a parasitic force that
definitely does not have our best
interest at heart
to me fungi are one of the most
fascinating mysterious sometimes scary
and sometimes charming organisms in our
world they help break down wood
decompose leaf litter and create soil
they create things essential to us like
penicillin and aid in the production of
cheese bread and beer
they can give us sources of tons of
vitamins or minerals and decorate our
forest floors with whimsy or they can be
so poisonous that they kill you almost
instantly or take over brains and create
leagues of zombie insects
fungi in a sense control our world and
life as we know it would likely not
exist without them if you're like me and
love to look at mushrooms identify
mushrooms and eat mushrooms and prefer
the kind that doesn't turn you into a
zombie instantly then you should try
hello fresh which has tons of mushroom
and vegetable dishes to choose from
hello fresh has become a staple in my
life for weeknight meals i love to cook
but hate going to the grocery store it's
hard to find time and motivation to come
up with weeknight meal ideas let alone
go shopping for ingredients the average
trip to the grocery store takes 41
minutes with hellofresh you can skip
those trips and get everything you need
to make chef curated meals delivered to
your door you simply log on and view
your meal options for the upcoming week
and pick however many you would like
this is my favorite part as there are
always exciting meals to choose that i
would never have thought to make
like ricotta dollop gnocchi with
mushrooms walnut and sage um yes please
and on top of the regular meal kit
options hellofresh can deliver ready to
eat salads sandwiches and soups
sometimes i'm just not feeling very
creative with my cooking but hello fresh
can step in to help me show off and make
pretty impressive delicious meals my
friends and family rave about the hello
fresh meals i cook which definitely
boosts my ego even though it wasn't my
idea in many parts of the world the
weather is cooling off except texas and
you can choose from hello fresh's
seasonal selection of autumn themed
savory recipes and desserts like hearty
soups chilies and in-season fall produce
or ready to bake mini pumpkin
cheesecakes so if you're ready to free
up your time eat healthy meals and
improve your cooking skills go to
hellofresh.com and use code
realscience14
to get 14 free meals including free
shipping that's two whole weeks of free
dinners and if you're looking for
something else to watch right now you
can watch our previous video the insane
biology of the axolotl or watch real
engineering's latest video the problem
with solar energy in africa a great
video about the benefits and problems
that could come with putting solar
panels in the sahara desert to
potentially solve our energy crisis